mit technik gegen eine zweite welle seit
heute gibt es die staatliche app fürs
smartphone die verhindern soll dass sich
das corona virus ausbreitet
prozessbeginn im mordfall lübke
angeklagt ist ein mutmaßlicher
rechtsextremist er soll den cdu
politiker auf seiner terrasse erschossen
haben und strafaktion gegen einen
verbündeten us-präsident trampel
soldaten aus deutschland abziehen weil
berlin zu wenig geld in die rüstung
stecke
[Musik]
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber in allen guten abend
und willkommen bei uns beiden um 7 katja
hat nachher den sportlichen teil des
tages im blick ich grüße sie sich hin
und nimmt seit heute hat deutschland
eine offizielle corona waren app die mit
dazu beitragen soll zu erkennen ob man
mit einem infizierten kontakt hatte
diese app war lange in der diskussion
und hat auch ziemlich lange gebraucht in
der entwicklung
sie ist an ihrem ersten tag schon 1,4
millionen mal heruntergeladen worden
das ist auch wichtig denn das ganze
system funktioniert nur wenn viele
menschen diese app nutzen
zu finden ist sie in den app stores von
google und apple unter dem titel corona
waren app herausgeber ist das robert
koch institut die wichtigsten funktionen
erklärt jetzt wenn reden
so sieht die hauptseite der korona app
für alle nutzer heute aus eine graue
meldung für ein unbekanntes risiko die
app aktualisiert sich alle 24 stunden
erst danach errechnet das eigene telefon
die wahrscheinlichkeit eines möglichen
corona kontaktes dann springt die
anzeige auf grün alles gut oder auf rot
die entscheidung was dann passiert
trifft einzig der nutzer also ich würde
dann schon reagieren und vielleicht zum
arzt gehen und mich dann auch testen
lassen weil sonst brauche ich die app ja
auch nicht weil dann bringt das ja nicht
kennt man ja dann ist irgendwas
unheimlich wichtig und ich kann jetzt
aber nicht die nächste woche in
quarantäne oder so weiß ich nicht die
gefahr sehe ich eine der wichtigsten
funktionen der app ist die eingabe dass
der nutzer positiv auf kuwait 19
getestet wurde arzt oder testlabor
generieren dafür einen qr-code oder eine
tan nur so zum spaß kann also niemand
einen corona alarm auslösen wenn der
alarm dann bei allen kontakten des
infizierten ankommt empfiehlt die etwas
zu tun ist
was mache ich damit klassischerweise
wenn mal eine woche in quarantäne gehen
ja dann wird natürlich die frage geklärt
kann ich mich dann krank schreiben
lassen ja selbstverständlich natürlich
musste hier vorher garantieren ganz
genauso die app arbeitet mit der neuen
bluetooth schnittstelle die apple und
google geschafft
die verbraucht angeblich sehr wenig
strom aber sie verbraucht strom also
deutschen mobilfunk anbieter berechnen
für den datenverkehr der app nichts
nichts dagegen mit der europäischen
zusammenarbeit bislang frankreich nutzt
eine komplett andere technik andere
länder entwickeln ihre apps noch setzen
aber auf den neuen bluetooth standard
die deutsche corona waren app das hat
auch die eu kommission heute
durchblicken lassen könnte dabei eine
gute vorlage seien in berlin heute
erleichterung dass die app jetzt am
start ist minister entwickler das
robert-koch-institut sie alle halten die
korona waren app für sinnvoll und sicher
aber es bleiben auch noch fragen nicole
diekmann viele pressekonferenzen dienen
naturgemäß dem zweck etwas als gut zu
verkaufen
auf dieser pressekonferenz aber kamen
superlative wirklich außergewöhnlich oft
zum einsatz
das ist nicht die erste corona app
weltweit die vorgestellt wird
aber ich bin ziemlich überzeugt es ist
die beste sie herunterzuladen und zu
nutzen das ist ein kleiner schritt für
jeden von uns aber ein großer schritt
für die pandemie bekämpfung auch der
gesundheitsminister stolz tatsächlich
viel lob von fachleuten für die vanek
dass er sie verführt angekündigt und mit
der forderung nach einer zentralen
speicherung für viel ärger und eine
nötige kehrtwende gesorgt hatte davon
kein wort mehr
dass die app kurz vor sommer ferien und
urlaubszeit noch nicht europäisch
abgestimmt ist redet er lieber klein es
gibt ja einige länder da sind auch viele
deutsche gleichzeitig im urlaub da macht
es dann schon ein unterschied und viele
sind in deutschland im urlaub ebenfalls
zufrieden die
bundesverbraucherschutzministerin
beauftragte für den datenschutz dieser
app ein sehr gutes zeugnis ausstellt das
zeigt wie weit wir auch gekommen sind
doch der legt heute den finger in die
wunde momentan sind gerade mal 20
prozent der labore in der lage patienten
ihr ergebnis digital zu übermitteln so
dass die app damit arbeiten kann
viele getestete müssen deshalb
stattdessen den umweg über eine
telefonhotline gehen keine gute lösung
sagt der datenschutzbeauftragte linke
und grüne fordern ein gesetz zur app
dort muss es eine absolute zweckbindung
geben eine harte befristung bis zum ende
der pandemie und eine gesetzliche
verankerung der freiwilligkeit gegenüber
dem staat aber auch gegenüber dritten
die befürchtung gründen könnten zur
nutzung der app gezwungen werden aber
auch arbeitnehmer unwahrscheinlich sagt
die groko ein gesetz sei unnötig
die korona vanek viel zufriedenheit aber
auch noch viele offene fragen und
wichtige informationen zur corona app
zum nachlesen online bei uns zum
beispiel die frage was tun wenn die app
anzeigt dass man einem infizierten
begegnet ist
antworten dazu in unserer app zdf heute
und jetzt heute abend eine nachricht die
hoffnung machen kann in dieser pandemie
sie kommt aus großbritannien wo eine
groß angelegte studie der uni oxford zum
ersten mal überhaupt ein medikament
identifiziert hat das bei schweren
fällen von kogit 19 die gefahr senkt zu
sterben
das medikament heißt dexamethason es ist
bereits überall vorhanden und es kostet
wenig dann müssen noch mal nachfragen
bei andreas stamm in london genannt
andreas das ist jetzt ein erster
hoffnungsschimmer wie zuversichtlich
sind denn die britischen wissenschaftler
äußerst zuversichtlich muss man sagen
denn es ist eben das erste medikament
das in einer groß angelegten klinischen
studie mit mehr als 6000 patienten
wirklich signifikant leben gerettet hat
natürlich muss man sagen erstens diese
ergebnisse sind noch nicht unabhängig
überprüft das heißt immer mit vorsicht
zu genießen und zweitens jemand der an
corona erkrankt das kann das medikament
nicht verhindern kann auch weiter schwer
erkrankten das virus bleibt genauso
gefährlich und schwere
krankheitsverläufe
also dann auch weiter auf der
intensivstation aber wenn man sich das
anschaut fasst die da ausgerechnet haben
heißt das von acht schwer erkrankten
die sterben würden kann das medikament
eine person retten
und man macht mal ein rechenbeispiel für
großbritannien hätte man das mit dem
medikament benutzt hätte man das gewusst
wären von den bis zu 60.000 toten 5000
menschen noch am leben bei ihren
freunden und familien und das ganze für
einen preis pro behandlung unter 50 euro
weltweit verfügbar
dexamethason ist also mehr als nur ein
erster silberstreif am horizont und das
denken nicht nur die briten sondern auch
viele wissenschaftler in deutschland und
in aller welt
dexamethason den namen sollten uns erst
mal merken herzlichen dank andreas da
gucken uns jetzt die zahlen bei den
infizierten in deutschland ran die die
korona neuinfektion gehen weiter zurück
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage haben sich täglich 220 menschen neu
angesteckt seit ausbruch der pandemie
hat die johns hopkins universität mehr
als 188 1000 infizierte gezählt davon
gelten fast 173000 als genesen 8800 16
menschen sind in verbindung mit 19
gestorben
wer studiert und wegen corona in geldnot
geraten ist kann seit heute eine
überbrückungshilfe beantragen
viele studierende haben ja ihren
nebenjob verloren zum beispiel in der
gastronomie für drei monate können sie
jetzt bis zu 500 euro pro monat bekommen
zurückzahlen müssen sie das geld nicht
den antrag gibt es online der bedarf
muss nachgewiesen werden insgesamt
stellt der bund 100 millionen euro zur
verfügung
unser nächstes thema in frankfurt am
main hat heute ein prozess begonnen auf
den dieses land ganz besonders schaut es
geht nicht nur um die tat selbst sondern
auch um ihre politischen hintergründe
der mord an walter lübke
vor gut einem jahr wurde der kasseler
regierungspräsident auf der terrasse
seines hauses erschossen
der hauptangeklagte ist er stefan ernst
er und sein mutmaßlicher helfer gelten
als rechtsextremisten sie sollen aus
hass gehandelt haben weil lübke sich für
flüchtlinge einsetzte aus frankfurt
christoph schneider die kontrollen und
der besucher andrang zum prozessauftakt
die ersten zuschauer und journalisten
hatten sich bereits mitten in der nacht
angestellt um den prozess verfolgen zu
können
und er ist der hauptangeklagte stefan
ernst
hier steht er inmitten seiner beiden
verteidiger in der vorderen reihe sitzt
der mitangeklagte markus h mit seinen
anwälten 46 jährigen ernst wird
vorgeworfen in der nacht vom ersten auf
den 2 juni vergangenen jahres den
kasseler regierungspräsidenten walter
lübke auf der terrasse von dessen
wohnhaus in wolfhagen easter erschossen
zu haben
die anklage der bundesanwaltschaft
lautet auf mord ausschlaggebend für
diese tat war ein von rassismus und
fremdenfeindlichkeit getragenes tatmotiv
der angeklagte zielte darauf ab die aus
seiner sicht missliebige
flüchtlingspolitik die haltung die herr
doktor lobte in diesem zusammenhang
vertrat abzustrafen
auch nebenkläger sind zum prozess
gekommen unter ihnen die witwe und die
beiden söhne des getöteten bald alle für
sie spricht ihr anwalt wir die
nebenklage wollen alle umstände zur
mordtat erfahren die planung die
durchführung täter und teilnehmer
mitwisser beweggründe
kurz nach prozessen stellen ernst
verteidiger auch einen
befangenheitsantrag gegen den
vorsitzenden richter das mammut
verfahren soll vorerst bis ende oktober
dauern
felix zimmermann ist hier bei mir aus
unserer rechts redaktion er war heute
auch beim prozessauftakt in frankfurt
mit dabei felix bunten abend welcher
persönlicher eindruck bleibt denn jetzt
von diesem ersten tag
mich hat besonders beeindruckt wie die
familie lübke also seine ehefrau und
seine beiden söhne heute stefan ernst
gegen übertragen
die saas und standen direkt gegenüber
des mutmaßlichen mörders ihres vaters
bzw
ehemanns und schauten in die ganze zeit
direkt ins gesicht fragen und
herausfordernd und die wollen antworten
und die würde auch das gericht der
vorsitzende sagebiel appellierte an die
angeklagten gestehen sie wenn es etwas
zu gestehen gibt ob sie sich jetzt
tatsächlich im prozess einlassen werden
ist noch unklar
das ist die juristische seite fragen wir
noch mal etwas weiter gefasst was kann
man denn von diesem prozess
erwarten insgesamt für unsere
gesellschaft viele hoffen sicher
aufklärung über ungeklärte fragen etwa
darüber ob davon ernst und sagen
mutmaßlicher komplize teil eines
rechtsradikalen netzwerks war auch warum
stefan ernst vom paar des
verfassungsschutzes verschwand obwohl er
nachweislich als brandgefährlich kite
doch so ein strafprozess kann solche
interessanten fragen meist leyen nicht
klären
dort geht es wirklich nur darum ob den
angeklagten die konkret angeklagten
taten nachgewiesen werden können und
wenn ja wie sie dafür zu bestrafen sind
nicht mehr und nicht weniger kann ein
strafprozess meistens leisten wichtige
hintergrund fertig hat sich ein dank
dafür
und damit kommen wir zu unserem nächsten
thema heute abend das verhältnis
zwischen deutschland und den usa
ein besonderes verhältnis ein wichtiges
verhältnis aktuell ist es besonders
schlecht
der amerikanische präsident will
tausende us soldaten aus deutschland
abziehen
das hat er jetzt offiziell bestätigt und
zwar als eine art denkzettel
im moment sind in deutschland etwa
34.500 amerikanische soldaten
stationiert 9500 von ihnen sollen gehen
begründung von donald trump deutschland
zahle zu wenig für verteidigung und
außerdem würden die usa beim thema
handel benachteiligt armin coerper
berichtet gedroht hatte er oft jetzt
macht er ernst präsident trump in der
vergangenen nacht ein paukenschlag
deutschland schuldete nato milliarden
dollar seit jahren das müssen sie
bezahlen wir sollen deutschland
verteidigen und die zahlen nicht das hat
keinen sinn trampel truppen aus
deutschland abziehen seit jahrzehnten
stehen die für amerikas partnerschaft
geknüpft trump offenbar an bedingungen
im politischen berlin ringt man um worte
mancher natur sich fast schwer damit den
mann aus amerika noch als führungsfigur
anzusehen als vielmehr inkasso
eintreiber vor dem hintergrund wie er
meint dass deutschland oder andere
staaten nicht gebührend
militärische ausgaben machen es ist ein
komplett anderes verständnis als das was
ich habe die tonalität des
amerikanischen präsidenten kann ein ja
fast gar nicht mehr überraschen ich
werte die jetzige entscheidung nicht
sicherheitspolitisch sondern eher
wahlkampftaktisch profitieren könnte
polen wo regierung und bevölkerung seit
jahren auf mehr us-truppen hoffen aus
angst vor dem nachbarn russland aus
minister mars heute in warschau ein
besuch bei konkurrenten um die gunst
washington
ich möchte unterstreichen dass unsere
gesprächen mit den amerikanern in keinem
zusammenhang stehen mit deren plänen aus
deutschland truppen zu verlegen
wann die usa ihre soldaten abziehen und
wohin das hat donald trump bisher nicht
gesagt doch für deutschland ist die
ankündigung ein zeichen dass die alte
schutzmacht amerika auf dem rückzug ist
noch mal nachgefragt bei unserer man in
washington immer was ist das jetzt ein
neuer tiefpunkt in den gemeinsamen
beziehungen mit einem präsidenten der
nicht nur droht sondern geradezu
bestraft also es ist in erster linie
tatsächlich wohl wahlkampf donald trump
sieht im grunde und die amerikanische
präsenz das engagement in aller welt das
militärische als eine art
geschäftsbeziehung an
das hat auch ein sprecher des nationalen
sicherheitsrates einmal gesagt es geht
um den bestmöglichen deal für das
amerikanische volk
und wenn man den nur bekommt wenn man
droht wenn man bestraft dann kommt das
gut an bei seinen anhängern
er kann auch damit ein stück weit
ablenken von fehlern die er gemacht hat
zum beispiel im umgang mit der korona
krise da steht deutschland ja deutlich
besser da als die us regierung und das
ist sich eher um wahlkampf handelt sieht
man vielleicht auch darin dass bisher
noch keinerlei vorbereitungen getroffen
worden sind für diesen truppenabzug das
kann monate dauern
und selbst die republikaner im kongress
glauben eher dass es hier um den
kurzfristigen nutzen als um den
langfristigen schaden geht denn der wird
angerichtet deutschland ist als
drehscheibe für amerikanische
operationen im nahen osten und in afrika
derzeit eigentlich unersetzlich elmar
theveßen center for schenken dankeschön
schauen wir jetzt auf einen brennpunkt
dieser welt wo sich die hoffnung die
lage könnte sich beruhigen
gerade wieder zerschlägt der konflikt
nämlich zwischen nord und südkorea an
der streng bewachten grenze dort hat
nordkorea ein verbindungsbüro also eine
art gemeinsame botschaft gesprengt und
zuvor bereits die kommunikation gekappt
machthaber kim jong un ist verärgert
über eine flugblattaktion von
südkoreanischen aktivisten ein
rückschlag nicht nur für die beiden
nachbar völker auch für die
abrüstungsinitiative des us präsidenten
ulf röller um 14 uhr 50 ortszeit
sprengte nordkorea das verbindungsbüro
in die luft es galt als symbol des
friedens die hoffnung auf eine
annäherung der beiden länder ging in
rauch auf in südkoreas hauptstadt seoul
reagieren sie fast schon routiniert auf
die bedrohung
können verdrängen nordkoreas aktionen
erschrecken uns nicht jedenfalls haben
sie uns heute nicht beschlossen
vor zwei jahren hielten koreas mächtige
männer noch symbolträchtig händchen zu
romantischer musik
doch nach dem schönen bildern ist nichts
mehr passiert
nordkorea hält weiter an seinem
nuklearprogramm fest und leidet weiter
unter den harten wirtschaftssanktionen
kim jong-un hofft durch drohungen
lockerung zu erzwingen vor allem der
konflikt zwischen china und den usa
hilft ihm sollte nordkorea ernsthafte
militärische provokationen verüben würde
china trotzdem nicht washington
unterstützen zusätzlich harte
strafmaßnahmen zu verhängen
vor zwei jahren weckten der us-präsident
und der nordkoreanische diktator auf dem
gipfel in singapur
große hoffnungen auf entspannung die hat
kim jong un mit dem heutigen tag in die
luft gesprengt alte feindschaften
brechen wieder auf und die gefahr eines
militärischen konflikts in der region
wächst wieder
das verbindungsbüro stand nahe der
grenze zu südkorea nordkorea will dort
jetzt wohl soldaten stationieren
so jetzt wird friedlicher änderung erste
sport 32 spieltag in der fußball
bundesliga und das könnte heute der
titel vergeben werden
gewinnen die bayern bei den
abstiegsbedrohten bremen ist die sache
klar
dann sind sie zum dreißigsten mal
deutscher meister corona bedingt ist
eine balkon party nicht geplant die
achte meisterschaft nacheinander aber
fest bayern will an diesem drittletzten
spieltag den deckel auf die
ungewöhnliche saison machen und sich in
bremen zum geist lässt
für ihren trainer hansi flick warnt aber
vor berger und seiner momentanen v
gerade im letzten spiel haben sie auch
gezeigt dass sie eine offensive enorme
qualitäten haben und deswegen ist es so
dass ja dass da noch alles drin ist fünf
tore zuletzt in paderborn die hanseaten
schöpfen wieder hoffnung im
abstiegskampf ein selbstläufer wird
bayerns meisterfeier sicher nicht doch
das spiel ist für münchner auch die
chance auf eine revanche vor 16 jahren
kehrte werder als meister aus münchen
zurück heute abend könnten die bayern
fröhlich feiernd bremen verlassen anfang
2022 findet in ungarn und der slowakei
die nächste handball em statt vor gut
zwei stunden wurden in wien die gruppen
für die qualifikation ausgelost
deutschland steht dabei vor einer
lösbaren aufgabe
deutschland im topf der besten handball
nation europas zugelost zur gruppe 2
sicher nicht die schwierigste germany am
interessantesten die beiden duelle mit
österreich dem co-gastgeber der letzten
em deutschland im januar klarer sieger
wurde fünfter die österreicher achter
unser ziel ist natürlich die genossen
werden ohne frage aber ihren ersten
gerade im osten hin sind sehr sehr gut
seit februar im amt wartet noch immer
auf sein erstes länderspiel
ein trainingslager im märz dann kam
corona die ersten beiden der sechs
qualifikationsspiele sind im november
geplant nicht allzu steinig scheint der
weg unter die 24 besten teams die im
januar 22 den europameister aus spielen
sollen
und hoffentlich auch werden schon seit
ich 17 oder 28 das sind die
höchsttemperaturen morgen in deutschland
ganz schöne bandbreite gleich bei katja
horneffer ich empfehle ihnen das heute
schon mit der kollegin marietta slomka
21.45 sie hat fragen an den chef des
kanzleramts zur corona waren ab morgen
gibt es uns wieder punkt 7 vom gesamten
team danke dass sie dabei waren und in
allen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
den namen meine damen und herren sie
drehen sich ja ganz munter diese beiden
tiefs über europa aber sie ziehen kaum
von der stelle
und das hat kuriose konsequenzen für
unsere höchsttemperaturen heute mittag
lagen die werte hier in sankt petersburg
bei 28 grad und damit genauso hoch wie
in südspanien in cordoba ganz üblich für
mitte juni sind dagegen unsere
nachttemperaturen sinken auf 15 grad in
der lausitz und bis 9 grad an den alpen
dazu fällt in der nacht kaum regen in
der feuchten luft bildet sich allerdings
etwas nebel im nordosten ist es dagegen
klar und dort scheint dann morgen auch
von tag beginn an die sonne sonst gibt
es mehr wolken und auch schon die ersten
regenschauer und gewitter und die weiten
sich dann am nachmittag aus da können
durchaus unwetter dabei sein also
gewitter die mit hagel platzregen und
sturmböen verbunden sind dass vor allen
dingen in den westlichen mittelgebirgen
im westen und süden liegen morgen den
höchsttemperaturen bei 17 bis 24 grad im
nordosten gibt es sommerliche 25 bis 28
grad
dieses schmale regen und gewitter band
das wird am donnerstag langsam weiter
nach norden ziehen
am freitag erreichte es die ostsee und
am samstag verlässt es uns nordwärts
dann gibt es einige schöne abend noch